poi risponde registro blog di
prendendoti dal dall'armadio ok c'è
ragazzi prendete per questa cagata del
blog al contrario come la mia stanza in
grossa quanto una tana per pochi quindi
è una roba minuscola ho dovuto mettere
non c'è
ho messo un comodino che non so da dove
cazzo l'ho preso l'ho messo lì un puffo
sopra a caso siccome non sapevo dove
mettere il microfono preso una colonna
proprio di quelle romane e ciò cliccato
sopra il microfono a caso cioè tipo
perché non avete chiesto di fare un
blocco al contrario è bella a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video sono
fa vj e oggi siamo in un nuovo lloyd
anche se è al contrario voi non avete
idea ragazzi quanto cazzo ci ho messo a
mettere tutta la pro passato gli ultimi
40 minuti a cercare di mettere bene il
puffo sono quello per la colonna dovuto
chiedere a giulio cesare
però in affitto prima di cominciare
ragazzi con la solita devi partire con
la parte della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da qui asiana
che ha fatto questo spero sia un nome
vero caliano perché sennò faccio una
figura di merda ma non importa è bella
lo stesso perché sono mexico la rosa
detto questa ragazzina di passare di
news perché allora ho iniziato aria aim
is all action che ve l'avevo detto che
l'avrei fatto che lo stavo aspettando da
un anno bravo detto forse non ve lo
ricorderete nemmeno facciamo ricordo
manco io le partite un po lento però la
sedia sarà strepitosa vedrete più avanti
lasciam perdere a innanzitut ringrazio
perché blog di los angeles è piaciuto un
casino anzi non ho mai fatto un blog
così ho paura che non vi piacesse invece
piaciuto un casino ragazzi siete venite
venite vi abbraccio e siccome mi è
piaciuto così tanto volevo chiedervi
piacerebbe se facessi video anche del
genere ogni tanto andava da qualche
parte al mese prossimo dovrei non lo so
però dovrei andare al blizzcon che
presente sarebbe la fiera della blizzard
è una casa di che fa video giochi e
videogiochi sono che così si giocano al
computer e il computer sono quelli che
usano gli esseri umani agli esseri umani
sono persone senza cuffie quando faccio
tipo bear grylls che vado in giro potrei
fare blog come quello di los angeles
quindi volevo chiedervi se se vi piace
come cosa non gli faccia [ __ ] ma
se vi piace fatemelo sapere così almeno
lo so e li faccio quindi ragazzi siccome
non c'è soltanto news da dire stavolta
possiamo direttamente passare
pronto sto parlando veloce mi chiami
capisco manco io come non avevo tante
news da dire possiamo passare allo
scarpeccio dei pacchi
adesso della galatea fanno tramite
veloce non capisco un cazzo non voglio
quindi non per informazioni rivolgersi a
medico non somministrare minori 12 anni
mi chiamo un futuro f è un problema
adesso perché non so dove cazzo metterli
questo ragazzi sarà uno scarto più
ok a saranno scattato più difficile
della storia perché mi crollerà tutto
addosso da un momento all'altro
comunque migliaio rischio di sfondare
tutto stavolta ragazzi ciò tre pacchi e
palle oltre [ __ ] john tre pacchi da
aprire più questo che un tubo a caso di
ripartire dal tubo ragazzi perché è
troppo bello e in apribile
ho sempre desiderato un tubo nero sempre
minchia temuto per la mia vita una cosa
a un disegno mi chiamo esce godzilla e
un disegno enorme tra l'altro ragazzo è
una cosa o dio dobbiamo ammirare questi
capolavori ragazzi non avere questo è
troppo figo specialmente la mia faccia
in alto a destra è bellissima e fini
ragazzi c'è anche una lettera che devo
leggere assolutamente da gaia ciao
ghayatt da poster fa visse il mio idolo
da quando vedi finito mi sono fissata
con la nutella e la patata brava
figliola ps non fa intendere la parola
patata perfetto gran brava che lei
precisato faceva strana e gli passare al
prossimo ragazzi anche se mio dio lo fa
abbiamo ragazzi stavolta perché se butto
giù qualcosa tipo i micro potrei
rischiare seriamente di incazzarmi
quindi meglio evitare ma odio una una
tastiera è rotta fantastiche ragazzi
grazie ma è bella e funzionante tra
l'altro problema è che manca tutto il
pezzo dietro per ora ma che non funziona
anche il caso non si trova un attimo è
un mazzo di figurine dei simpson grazie
di cuore veramente anche se non le
colleziona però farò un personaggio a
caso di simpson meadows e la zecca marge
cazzo cielo quale dai più meglio è e
adesso lo sgozza pacchi confavi j
te lo saresti spesso la violenza sui
pacchi perché no allora voi mi spiegate
perchè adesso voi mi spiegate perché mi
avete inviato un sacco pieno di roba
perché personalmente preso babbo natale
primo regalo di oggi ragazzi la matita
rosa di di pippo per c'è una sto coso
cioè abbiamo gli stessi capelli ragazza
siamo due gemelli praticamente allora
ditemi perché perché perché il senso lo
trovate per favore per concludere ghazi
gli occhiali di harry potter che si
riconoscono subito che sono quelli di
harry potter perché hanno proprio
scritto sopra harry potter e come
l'ultimo ragazzine di procedere con
questo contiene 6 bottiglie da 75
centilitri c'è mi avete preso per un
alcolizzato io non bevo lega pro grazie
lo stesso un'agenda di youtube con
scritto fa vj credo sia fa vj non
perfetto perso la da adesso in avanti
ragazzi mi devo chiamare feed j senza la
perché non ce l'ho più gentile samsung
galaxy s 4 mini e dal peso devo dedurre
che qua dentro non c'è un cazzo di
niente a chi è piaciuto lo scherzo è
simpatico si sono cascati in pieno mio
dio c'è anche un kit mario prudente una
maggior seriamente pensavo di potermi
costo biglietto ci mancherà possono
essere così stupido non accorgermi che
una puttanata sticazzi 20 ragazzi dopo
la trovata del secolo ieri passare al
famigli sponde la prima domanda ragazzi
arriva da iron boss che mi chiede
famiglia manda perché tu favi rispondi a
tutte le nostre favi domande noi fa vi
rispondiamo alle tue favi domande ma
fabi sta minkia visto chimera fa
risponde voglio un tuo parere su questo
è l'ultima volta è finita male quando ho
fatto così però
[Musica]
ho visto abbastanza vince 2000 fa
rispondere il più di un milione di
iscritti su un milione e facciamo che ti
fanno la domanda in 300mila perché
perché ne risponde solo a 34 gol alla
volta che ci sono altre 290 nel 1996 6
bravo in matematica la risposta è molto
semplice di allora se ci sarà 299.000
996 domande come cazzo fa una persona
essere umano in un blog a rispondere a
290 3.996 domande a chi casi son 20
allora il primo è che o faccio un blog
che parte da adesso e finisce nel 2027
oppure sticazzi ragazzi a parte il fatto
delle domande adesso ne approfitto per
questa cosa mi arrivano al giorno
all'incirca 1000 1500 messa più o meno
messaggi sia su facebook che su youtube
che sulla pagina casinò quindi ragazzi
io cerco di rispondere alla maggior
parte delle persone impiego tantissimo
tempo per farlo però ragazze non riesco
a rispondere a tutti la carica per i
miei impossibile è impossibile a nel
prossimo blog risponderanno a 2280 1996
messaggi questo è sicuro se mi sa di che
cos'è un illuminato la risposta è molto
semplice te la spiego illuminati sono
una setta segreta che secondo gli
studiosi è nata nell'ambito cazzate
questo è un illuminato perfetto ragazzi
la battuta squallida del giorno l'ho
fatta prima di concludere ragazzi come
al solito passo la favino mandela favi
domanda di oggi è oggi la faccia seria
perché l'ultima volta è stata demenziale
al massimo che siano ragazzi di serie
che preferite di più tra range game
horror e divertenti poi devo sapere qui
sopra i commenti ragazzi io come al
solito concluso file episodio e quindi
ragazzi servizio è piaciuto vaso di
coccio documento mi piace anche a page
di facebook come ogni viso trovata una
descrizione per i formatori ott esame di
consumi stranieri 12 06 avresti scritto
ci vediamo il prossimo video belle
ragazze